thank you to Harry's and expressvpn for
sponsoring more on them after the Rea
show citizens of the reject Nation
Andrew Gordon and I have been having
such a fun time covering these guy
Richie films and we are doing the one
easily that the comments have been
requesting the most it is called the
Andrew aka the gentlemen Andrew how
excited are you well all right all right
all right I'm excited Greg I know it's
not as good as our STM uh impersonations
I'm really excited just from all the uh
doing a pervert what was that I if you
know what a pervert sounds like you tell
me but anyways I excited miror from all
the comments we've interrupting you
thank you cra I appreciate it's not easy
to keep going while you interrupt me but
from all the comments we've been getting
on the request uh for this specific guy
Richie film I'm super excited and also
two from the last guy Richie films we've
done I really love both those films so
I'm extremely excited for this one
looking forward to it guys is this your
favorite guy Richie film leave it down
below are you excited for the Netflix
series that we just learned was coming
out when we were trying to find out
where we can stream this leave it down
below leave a like subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified
when our reaction for a movie is up in
the channel you're like yeah that sounds
like my jam also thanks to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
and thank you to all who have been
joining us on this Miraculous Journey at
our patreon on page becoming super sexy
rejects over there you get the full
length reaction where you can sync up
with your own copy it's a full length
Reaction watch along and we also cover
several things over there exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs
included lost my my breath there was
swallowing my spit it's a Monday that
we're filming this let's do
[Music]
it whoa this is weird now the movie
starting over the Studio logo I like
that always stylistic choices with kyi
Bobby what I have a pint in a pickled
egg up it's a very specific pickled egg
order you know Matthew mcon doesn't wear
deodorant fun fact is that true true
yeah his dad said he should smell like a
man oh okay gry ah good
catch made himself an Easter egg if you
wish to be the king of the jungle I do
it's not enough to act like a king okay
you must be the king don't wear
deodorant don't fake it till you make it
don't
deodorant there can be no doubt because
doubt Causes Chaos in one's own demise
that's cool interal narration that he
was actually thinking it wasn't just a
narration for the story I love guy
Richie style I really I really Do's got
such cool variety he really does stay
night tonight 9:00 you and I River Cafe
who's
there Roz who's there oh [__]
whoa my what what a reveal at the
beginning I mean they're probably going
to do like a of course of course but
knowing the whole film that's going to
happen oh my God got some major
nonlinear storytelling to unfold Charlie
Ham's in this
cool Henry Golding this like a bond open
yes right this a cool cast
man and Hugh Grant Man from Uncle he's
back guy Richie he always picks such I
mean it's early on but he always picks
such good songs in his films it feels
like it's going to feel a little bit
more like the guy Richie that when he
was first came onto the scene with a
gangster
films wow this looks like an Ikea a
commercial in Britain or
something
fler I've got a meeting on Saturday at
your favorite newspaper I love the voice
he's doing they are ready to put 150
Grand in my pocket to give him some
filth good for me that but in this case
it's bad for you oh it's fun seeing him
play a character so big Dave editor
extraordinaire has developed a terrible
antipathy for your boss he's out to
destroy it we both know that your boss
has very very deep pockets and I would
like to invite him just to have a teeny
rumage in them ah what the [__] are you
talking
about furnish me with 20 million British
pounds I will give you memory cards
contact sheets recordings the lots and a
modest little screenplay Bush that's a
steep ride R in 30 seconds that you're
lucky because that is nothing compared
to what I could be asking thank God
you're not greedy Fletcher you deluded
[__]
eating
jeez quite like it when you talk dirty
to me I can feel myself in
ging drink with me it's really yummy
loving the sex oh man I imagine he had
so much fun getting a chance to really
step out of what he normally does you
play a game with me B I don't want to
play a game please no I said play aing
game with me
R oh cool great editing go from far away
and then close up on those two lines and
back and forth here I want you to
imagine a character a dramatic character
like in a book or a play or a film but
not digital analog chemical process keep
the Grain in the picture I say old
school 35 mil are we watching it I was
wondering if lot right when he said it
yeah I'm seeing this through a lens I am
and I'm not talking about the small
screen it's not TV Raymond as I said old
school right okay is this guy Richie
talking to us yeah R
camera so cool enter our protagonist I
had a okay he's gorgeous he's Golden Age
he's a proper handsome his name is
Mickey Pearson the betterness of this
American Born Road scholar so he's born
clever but poor I relate but he never
finished his education because he found
his vocation a naughty vocation he's a
bad boy that substance looks familiar he
starts stealing the dirty Wonder weed to
his rich British upper class uni Pals ah
he's an entrepreneur yeah man drug
dealer
entrepreneur what's the
difference he had to do some naughty
things to get where he got to establish
his position to become king to show he
was wasn't just teeth tits and
tan well he wasn't fing H was he
oh he had an engine under his hood and
in his holster machete does not look
real well that was the early days and he
cracked on with his new world Pioneer
Spirit what's he worth today 100 200 500
million I wonder if in person I would be
able to keep up with everything H Grant
is saying like can you put this in
subtes while you're talking to me
cashing his chips and get out the game
and he seems to have found the perfect
customer smash cut
please has been cultivating a special
relationship with the erudite learned
and broadminded Matthew burer I do know
about the Jewish billionaire Cowboy
Jewish
billionaires Matthew Burger blindsiding
us with his donation to build the entire
cognitive behavioral therapy unit he
sold him some weed earlier they've done
some small deals together they for the
big one now I understand why you're
seated at the head of the table Making a
Splash with the Gentry oh I like to make
a splash whenever
possible understand the significance of
a proper attire I believe a sense of
ownership is vital in every aspect of
life perhaps never more so than when it
comes to wardrobe represents who you are
and for every season a strategy now
starts the alpha dogs they're not really
talking about clothes
Raymond I
know they're like a pair of old doggies
sniffing around one another's
intellectual [__] it's a good
oldfashioned cough
Rond it's fun how he's letting us know
we're watching a film itself like it's
very self-aware in that sense and it's
like his gangster film with but upper
Society you see try as I might I can't
work out how you do it and Bush is my
game how does anyone grow 50 tons of
Super Skunk without letting anyone else
know how they do it lots of practice 200
million gross PA 100 mil Jesus your
people know this already they've s the
numbers for months now I got to get into
a life of crime seriously right we're
wasting our time in here it was Big Dave
he commissioned me to do a job on Mickey
you know sniff about keep an eye on him
go through his bids reveal his sins good
bars is that the Lord pressfield is
Grace the Duke yeah once full fin line
to the throne apparently Mickey pearon
has squeaked his way into the crack of
his fat Posh
ass I need a man with your creativity
with your nose now you know you're my
favorite blood ant I love how animated
they get when they curse I've learned
off you lot you got to look after number
one and now's my turn sun is not going
up for me Ray it's going down I feel
like there's such a fascinating history
to hug Grant's character two months ago
your man Mickey made my man Dave feel
like a right idiot didn't accept his
hand Dave had gone after one of Mickey's
Lords it would appear that his lordship
had had a quick spin on one of his
attractive young footmen after the
splash shares crash ah sorbing again
Dave will do a feature on him but you're
Mickey he's got a fabulous set of balls
so he snubbed him in front of a crowd
that Dave could only wish he belonged to
you know Lords and Ladies the
sort excuse us
oo there is a reason why Matthew cannot
work out how Mickey does what he does
how does he grow 50 tons of white widow
Super Cheese every year that needs a lot
of space so where is the space who does
he bribe I want to know you have to be
be creative you need an angle problem
with land in this country is there's not
much of it and there's Public Access
even when it's supposed to be private
and the public have rights dog walkers
yes y
on right to roam bimblers Ramblers
Badger lovers and any other b c with
enough time on his
hand the structuring you have to do in
the editing room for something like this
yeah I a nightmare you must remember
that cash is very persuasive to the
class that got spanked by Angry lefties
and death
duties and every time you inherit a
fortune you lose half to the state mhm
and offer my services so they can keep
their houses in order and they're not
too bothered about what I do as long as
that cash keeps rolling in each year 12
sites you a dirty 12 Farms 1,000 of
these Estates in the great UK
interesting my infrastructure that sir
is with my blessing what you are paying
for wow what a cash flow but enough
foreplay Michael I want to see your
plant if you were standing on my bush
you wouldn't know it it's like
everyone's talk here is sex in some
way they're not talking about sex but
that is their language in the entire
time sexual innuendos delightful tool
shed for $400
[Music]
million Ooh La La this is connected to
all the homes
jeez this is my dream it's fake YouTube
location staff technology so you're
buying the substructure for the super
structure to come imagine they used
mirrors to make it look like there's
more so funny Matthew MCC has played
this
guy did you know it took 15 years after
alcohol prohibition ended back home for
the legal Market to scratch that itch H
mhm I mean Mar is becoming more and more
legal yeah and I'm not greedy you and I
both know that 400 million is a fair to
generous asking price I mean you'll make
that back pretty damn quick 200 billion
and well half a trillion
pounds annually the legacy of these
customers relying on illegal marijuana
White Widow super cheese it's the new
Gold Rush this is the thin end of a very
fat wedge sir I don't know what the laws
are and then London cuz like in
California be like yeah it's complet
was it's legal out here yeah I have no
idea what it is out there an Enterprise
like this we'll need a face with the
clean past exactly yeah we both know
growing is only 50% of the business I
need your European connections I've seen
how the sausage is made now tell me
about the butcher shops well that comes
later
Matthew many miles away another
beautiful feral Beast Lopes his way to a
watering no I talk Rondo
of what is he Chinese Japanese panes get
on your [__] knees Jesus yellow is a
color gambling is a God oh God like a
millennial
crack Oh Henry Golden Henry Golden
usually plays like such swab
elegancy dry eye like a Chinese James
Bond harass to kill that's the one I
know right there more like this RAC to
kill yeah it's an old school guy Reggie
not afraid to make his characters
racist ow him down load him up and come
off yeah this guy usually has such a
great err about him debbon air quality
it's kind of I'm excited to see him play
more of a gangster criminal rle I quoted
you for a 20 when it's a 40 footer it's
going to be double
bubble double
bubble a gentleman's quote is a
gentleman's word o I would not cross
this guy it's not to be trifled with
well your family are going to have to
pay for that lesson do we have an
understanding just say yes just listen
man you don't mess with snake eyes if
you're thinking of smoking that here
don't I find that confusing do you mean
don't smoke or don't think both you know
exactly what he
means oh he's really serious about this
it's going out it's going
out this movie is about illegal
marijuana
how funny I think the time has come for
me to introduce you to our Queen scatter
and cigarette
van the only weak link is his devotion
with his beautious lady wife this is a
sanctuary for the ladies where is he
it's up in your office of the oh my God
his car Shop's so
woke so what do you think ringing the
bell but not too loud dipped in noney
that's on the money so this is what we
call focus group guys what the is going
on in here I should have known it was
you behind this Rog is supposed to be
working down there and you're up here
blowing his brains out he works better
he's going to be he's going to have so
much more attention to detail or he's
going to totally botch it one of those
two one of two if word spreads that
you're getting out that could read as
weakness so you're going to have to
stamp that out without any
gentrification don't you do anything
messy that's why you've got people
remember she is so lucky why are you
wasting our time I know what happens in
my my world and what doesn't he stepped
outside you can smoke the cigarette I
blame him I would want my spelling why
Michael should be motivated to write you
a check for 20 million I am a
Storyteller there's any chance of a
stake all
right I haven't either it sounds good
I'll guess it mate oh no you're all
right just stay right
there m
it's
hot he's a Sly Fox that Fletcher indeed
oh oh my God looks like a young Valk
kilos night night asan oh man I thought
he was on the straight and arrow I
didn't I didn't think he was going to be
uh I thought he'd be like oh the the
good guy you know you got all these
parts on a 40ft container how'd you get
your hands on that ask no questions and
no lies so what surprise I mean with
your husband that's not going to happen
keep the PS consider ajust your Goodwill
I like what he's done with his teeth
yeah dry he got his it sit down with
Michael didn't he unsanctioned by the
dragon head himself Lord George but dry
ey oh he's next generation and them
chinen they upgrade quicker than
I big man PR behind Lord George's back
to be fair is very nicely played with
100 Grands worth of free car parts cuz
everyone knows that the way to a man's
heart is through his wife it's true
heyen
I would like you to consider an offer
well let me stop you right there this is
not a discussion for the two of us
unlike the salt and pepper it's not on
the
table this is a big number is it more
than 400 mil when is enough going to be
enough well you only verbally agreed to
the other guy right
gosh I am not for sale I want to know
how much it's on there even if I was
you're several zeros short now you may
be able to buy a man sausage for that
but to me it just looks rude at
breakfast you're have touch you don't
have to be so rude to this guy now when
the silver backs got more silver than
back he best move on before he gets
moved on it's not
dignified beneath you Michael trying to
do you a favor are we supposed to
suspect that it's Henry Golding who got
him killed oh at the beginning yeah
there's suspects and this oh this is a
big
gun w w
oh oh jeez eyes not so dry now are they
hurts does
it looking for your a hole in the wall
was this was this the right call there's
only one rule in Jungle damn when the
Lion's hungry he
eat I don't think it was Henry Golden I
think yeah I was wondering like I don't
know this character entirely but it
seems out a character that's not how
Michael works yeah I know no I know he's
just having a bit of fun well we did see
with the machete earlier on but just
didn't go that far every movie needs a
bit of action doesn't it and it's not
like Michael doesn't have a reputation
reputation he's been
gentrified
here oh okay never mind could be him
they need a little bit of action for the
movie was a young and foolish Dragon who
came to ask a wise and cunning lion
about acquiring his territory now the
lion he wasn't interest said so he do
the little dragon
off couldn't understand off me persisted
and continued to ask the lion about
acquiring his territory so the lion took
the little dragon for a walk and put
five bullets in his little dragon head
oh
Jesus now allegedly there's a message in
there I don't know what it is but you're
a clever boy dry eye if you can explain
it to me so you're saying you'll sell
Mickey was pleased he took that meeting
wasn't he yes it went very well things
started to unravel after that meeting
didn't Mickey get a rat infestation at
one of his Farms
o oh oh was like those are GoPros they
got on going to mess up his operation
it's not going to be worth
shnit
no no oh they're going to destroy
everything he said to'd be a bit of puff
yeah they weren't joking no don't do it
the fu are you not cover do you know who
owns this Gap he doesn't even see the
slightest bit
nervous what's this Teddy Bear's
Picnic just one at a time you that's
fancy a warm up for you JY bab three
Lads
three Colin
Ferell why you smell a we in here
now back two steps
Tri you're on you you're
up he warned you he oh you're going to
stop stop trigger don't you know
dance what he is like a Four Tops
tribute actor
something putting the gay back in Marvin
Gay I'm on fire over here let's come on
I need some back and forth come on I
need some back and
forth make it funny
you that's not funny this a point no no
not that go
again me with it
D oh
oh [__] slapping them now wake up Lads
Lo quick you're slow Lo hard in a bone
top come on down the gym we'll see what
we can do with just I'll Mentor you guys
are you the coach coach is earning he is
the coach coaching for Ernie what is it
balls in the back of the net I'm going
to include you you're our Mentor well I
don't know what you're talking about but
I don't like the sound of it you've
landed a load of sticky Bush oh walk
away it's too late we're at the gym now
I'm loading the van you took my van
we'll be back in 10 minutes I think you
need to see this boss oh my God col
Pearl is going to be the best part of
this whole
movie they uploaded a video crazy
picking up dra plants not 10 or 20
gentle I never get cracked
man's his legs nothing like posting a
crime you just
committed oh damn oh oh
damn
right
right ear oh no why are we watching
fight right because it's fight at one of
my
Farms making a rap song out
of oh I assume he knows who they stole
from yeah yeah know he knows put down
that box of scorpions follow Jim what
might be coach so is this operational
like train kids to become like boxers
but also to make them a part of like
gangs like it's like a gang at the same
time is the front a boxing gym or is
like it's it's all rolled into one I'm
already so fascinated by what this
is 1.9 million hits in one night Nikes I
mean a real fight with a music video
it's dances come on would watch it what
I think it is yeah the best version of
it tell me you didn't put that fine
no what was I thinking leaving your kids
alone supervised it's your fault take it
down now I've got to say I was impressed
they're on point Governor what a fun
mislead because it seemed like they were
going to whoop their asses that's great
mislead who'd be smart enough to find
one Mickey's farms and who would be bold
enough to make such a move especially to
film it all and then post it all online
because that is really rubbing your face
in it isn't it is that the guy he works
for f Grant I hear you might have had a
little trouble now you helped me before
when my source ran dry so I'm just
returning the favor it's a paper weight
to keep down all the paper I'm about to
give you well it looks like a gun and
it's a paper weight it's noisy Cricket
bad timing jeopardizing deals shutting
down Farms it would be an expensive
disaster if Mickey doesn't get this
cleaned up all right cuz if you don't
pay means I'm going to have to close
shop well I'm not going to pretend that
missing out on a million pounds
commission a year isn't going to hurt
someone I've just learned we need a
whole new roof
apparently
just there's such a quirkiness to some
of the like the real world stuff they
include and when it rains let me take
care of the roof that estate roof though
that be so much money yeah those aren't
cheap and they cover a lot of ground
Dave is going to bring Mickey down by
using an abusing Lord pressfield's much
beloved child Lord pressfield's daughter
has fallen for this power Noel smacked
out dark charm unbridled by distractive
parents too busy skiing on a Swiss House
to notice and too [__] stupid to care
jeez junkie Bic autotune singing
daughter shacked out with some smacked
out once upon a time pop star and all
after by Mickey Pearson I like we miss
her terribly Mickey I failed as a parent
she was particularly vulnerable only she
had better parenting or betterhelp.com
good pluging she's gone missing they've
asked us to find her bring her home well
I had a feeling you might ask me this
boss whether some due diligence I know
where she is oh she's on a South London
Council estate so tell our jurisdiction
I mean what if she doesn't want to come
it's going to get messy well that may be
true but you're still doing it but can't
you send Fraser instead no I can't send
Fraser instead you're my best man I want
you it's tough being the best man this
is where you step on stage and set the
Domino's flying every do you think
Charlie HUD him killed him it's very
ambiguous but like that we're asking
these questions do you think it's going
to be revealed or are we just not going
to know I think it'll be revealed we
have to know so disappointing if we
don't know yeah that would be too no I
just need a moment of your time it's
about Laura pressfield I don't know
anyone on that night sure course be much
easier for all parties concerned if I
could just step inside for a moment no
off the
[Music]
[__] as you was boys and
girls why does that actress look so
familiar I know I've seen her in
something maybe it was Spider-Man 3 I
can't remember I work for a man a
powerful man Michael Pearson who's
Michael P friend of her fathers runs
London's buff game the anomaly knows oan
where are you from I'm from Narnia
Disneyland that's close now Laura
father's asked us to bring you home
she's not going anywhere why you just
shut up man seriously just shut up you
know you're not in control of the
situation do your moment out of favor
and try the impossible make yourself
happy all right that was easy it's a
[__] hole anyway hey there's no need to
be disrespectful don't go please
wait cut his head off touch me again
I'll cut you on oh man dude he's scary
he's got such a calm and soft demeanor
but then he can come off in 180 scary in
si keep the kids in school for one
minute I love all the subex St oh I
think it was that guy was in the freezer
aen no there it is oh no
oh oh they going out off the
balcony
oh
what have you done oh that's not a gun
dear that's a paper weight of course it
is along with a family of six baby
bullets I mean there's some serious
consequences to
that uh she might need some rehab though
one of her Associates had an accident
fell out of a window
boss oh [__] or not the car stream
accident yeah more like a death really
head is depart moment oh no who was he
some Russian kid with tracks on his arms
Russian kid that doesn't sound good
maybe someone related to him is what
yeah gets Matthew
MCC Yep this is not ideal Oh I thought
it was a head there was his whole body
there lson we're going to need those
phones clean nle come on and catch me
little oh no
no gangsters proper naughty boys and all
that
bollock I come in peace I'm not trying
to steal it I'm trying to buy it good
money honest money honest money what
this one how much full bag and I'll be
gone wouldn't kill a kid how about you
give us that bag and be gone anyway oh
oh God kids don't poke the Bear right
hey oh
I love how they all ran and he
stayed although he would have shot him
if he ran so it didn't matter put the
phone on the ground there's such an
intensity to this movie there's a real
tension well done I had no idea that gun
the whole time did you no to reveal call
him somewhere I'm trying just give me a
second what are you do can I use your
toilet is he okay to give this kind of
information to him I mean he could wipe
him out at any second well the the shoot
the information could be elsewhere be
other traces and stuff that's true can't
just kill
them [__] you say come on you say oh
oh great St work
there
phone damn Hugh Grant you are an amazing
tracker
Story Time over is there a problem here
Ray I don't know is there a problem here
Fletcher no no problem no problem at all
yes I forgot to wash my
hands it's funny cuz it's more akin to
like the stuff he's done and stuff like
Lock Stock and snatch but yeah
stylistically it actually feels more
grounded than those where those are a
lot more flashy in it's editing and
execution I need that Chinese Gaz
address okay love it morning coach good
luck find out his weed we took and now
you tell me uhoh this is not the F time
to keep your cards close to your chest
just tell me his name is Mickey
Pearson BL me coach you're a gypsy too
been reading tea leaves got a crystal
barall that is not good news AR Mickey
Pearson is terrible news in the face of
aoid an expensive death so many options
son who offed
him I think it might be Charlie onam I
think you're probably right but I still
think it could have something to do with
that aen guy who can't wi off the
balcony it really feel like that's going
to come back on that note I'd like to
extend my apologies on their behalf my
boys they're naive my responsibility so
it's me that should be accountable for
their actions so I offer you my loyalty
until that debt is settled you ceral is
the [__] I love him in this I'm going to
need to know how your Lads got the
information about where our farm was
cited once we've overcome that little
challenge then we can talk oh man
charlot home is excellent too because he
just seems so welcoming but he's so
intimidating when it comes time for it
the acting in this is is really good his
name is fak sp with a pH so it sounds
like
FW
F we've met before haven't we Fu [__]
that's the one [__]
[__] how did you know the location I've
been dreading you for months R was given
the
address I can't breathe
I need that please all for hook for hook
down it's so like unexpectedly funny
man here take a blam now good
boy no no sh the inhaler we know these
guys are not good with their
cardiovascular the buildup of this room
because this just going faster and
faster could just be dry I doing it's
been getting bold lately yeah well they
still all work for Lord George it's like
a tumble weed effect of just Gathering
more and more crap and problems it just
keeps getting bigger and bigger and
faster there's a lot of emphasis on how
scary Mickey is but we really haven't
seen Mickey do anything that like scary
other than what didn't happen in that
one's action sequence they're more
focusing on the intellect of him what
you watching I'm watching the horse
teally the profile shot of him but his
back's turned to the camera from Hong
Kong my only Vice well that's not
strictly true is it meaning I've always
taken Vice to be the definition of any
criminal activity involving prostitution
pornography or drugs very fiscated I
facilitate I don't participate in any of
the aforementioned devices well
Justified what about te what about te
well that too is vice C caffeine is a
drug don't you know so is that what
you're here to talk to me about sweet
Mary Jane is my VI of choice as you well
know of course I'm addicted to selling
it not consuming it okay Matthew we got
here deal in marijuana sure I could see
there was more to be made and Shifting
the white or the brown powder as you so
chose you see my jam it it doesn't kill
anyone your poison is and always has
been the the destroyer of world up
inimer oh no what this woman do to
herself she's about to oh no your
facilitation is most definitely
participation yep but I'm not here to
give you a sermon on situational ethics
why the are you here what did you put in
the
tea
oh
going Exorcist
here burn it all down you're starting a
war with me George and I'm trying to
moonwalk with Elegance here but I'm
finding it very difficult just when I
said we haven't seen Mickey do anything
that
scary you didn't think I'd find out
having me followed for months you raided
one of my
locations you know the rules George oh
God you thinking you raided one of my
locations I think this is the same
composer Wrath of man as like the Menace
is still
[Music]
there such a sense of a dreary tone
always in this
film yet it's like fun yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure it's like the two guy
Richie worlds we've been introduced to
lately I can see you're feeling somewhat
under the weather
because I spiked your tea with a nasty
little parasitic genus called Chella I
suggest taking two of these fizzy
biscuits you'll be fine in an hour or
two long enough to consider your past
indiscretions that would be one way to
go on the [__] get to you in your own
kitchen I can get you anywhere surpris
Let Him Live did you raid Mickey
Pearson's Farm uh-oh so you're telling
me that [__] did this behind your back
well let's just say this he didn't do it
in front of it but you did go behind my
back and offer you buy his business I
don't see this ending well for Lord
George there comes a point where the
young succeed the old dude you're going
to get you're going to get murdered
right now there's something I don't know
about something between dry eye and Lord
George we're coming back to that scene
at some point whatever it was someone
killed Lord George anyone else might
think that was you or Mickey I know the
way guy Richie works at this point does
that arouse your interest Raymond so
Matthew no's dry eye oh interest
interesting you play dry eye I should be
Matthew try and get it in time with his
lips all right roll Camera
Action that was like a perfect cut and
edit right
[Applause]
there wow this is called el football
there was an incident Lord George excite
rymond spit
wooden the last thing you need to do is
attract in the octopus octopus what does
that mean it's not a very good
translation no there's nothing wrong
with the translation Matthew's not that
fluent and it's Cantonese Just go with
it and fill in the legs
and there will be repercussions for
Michael's actions you think you're
running th do you don't stroke my mouse
hair yeah I think what he means is don't
jeopardize my deal but I admit that
one's a bit of a googly I've never seen
new grand transform into a role before
this is real this is how it's going to
play out I'm going to back the off and
I'm going to take it all and you will
you seen coro's there's elements of
car's waed this I I never saw that one I
know 1993 Brian De Palma dry eye I trust
you will make Michael P pay for this the
Russian no solidify your position you'll
be done Uncle never mind definitely not
the
Russian oh this is it oh from the
beginning Hey it said g Richie yeah
maybe he was a mislead maybe he wasn't
actually shot maybe the other guy got
shot oh then hearing someone there
tipped him off that he was going to get
killed we're close hang up no hang the
phone up who's that oh is that uh dry
eye Raz who's there what you doing
Charlie yeah at this point I'm guessing
that you didn't even know that Lord
George was dead yet let alone what drye
was up to hello dry eye what do you
want it's like those slippers FY B
sweet so yourself the gun right there
yeah the gold gun
what Charlie Hunter must have got him
yeah yeah exactly yeah that was that's
what I what I said that just a little
bit of go you're not listening you're
two into the movie and I'm sorry what
did you
say I know but I heard you but I had to
like see it first good call though he's
not picking up maybe you should put your
seat Bel on yeah let me call Ros let me
do
it got to imagine the adrenaline is
going crazy right I love how he protects
him so
much could just slow down a little
bit
oh oh god really feel the impact of that
oh [__] and Guy Rich he had that so in
frame for a good five to six seconds to
come with me or Tony here he's going to
make you come with me you're in my
office under my roof it's not your
position for Tony to do anything other
than off back from Wy k I love
her what's that is that a paper we funny
should say that turns out anything with
weight can be a paper
weight either you do as I tell you to
and use the door or I'm going to shoot
Fat Tony right between the eyes you see
this gun's only got two bullets so I'm
not going to about illustrating its
significance T get on
it
ooh right between the
eyes I thought he was being tortured for
I didn't realize he was still in the
car
Nikes yep you dead man I dare
you just calm
down I'm
leaving oh same spot damn she got a
great shot she's so hot there only two
bullets guess that's your two bullets he
didn't she isn't there six two she said
there's two where's all the other
employees
oh what the hell
man hello
Bab
oh you are so
done [__] should have left when you had
the chance so you're basing your whole
Crescendo on a figment of your
imagination I'm basing my whole
Crescendo on the some of its parts
unreliable narration you are too smart
to be blackmailing us flet yeah that's
what I'm saying so I've taken
precautionary measures you can do all
kinds of horrible things to me if you
want I might even enjoy
them Matthew he's going to need some
people to run his business here when he
buys it from Michael right he promised
dry the job that's what that's what I
said it was Matthew who told dry ey the
location of Mickey's Farm exactly he's
the only one who knew the location but
what he did not plan on you
see was dry
ey W one step ahead killing Lord George
now dry eye does not want to be
subservient to Matthew anymore doesn't
want to be subservient to anyone oh damn
there is Henry Golden plays such like a
slimy ruthless character everyone so
many people are playing against tyer
I'll tell you how this plays out you
will drown and then my mad crabs will
eat you this is and this is why I want
my hard ear 20 million because not only
do I know how Mickey's business operates
but I also o know that the very man he's
trying to sell it to is trying to force
him into selling it on the chap yep that
if anything happens to me I I do have my
insurance policy in place everything
will go to Big Dave from him to the
public and you my love will go to Mars
strong recommendation just pay out you
seem terrified right now man 20 million
we got 72 hours starting now tick tock
tick tock I would have blackmailed the
the other guy um what's his name Matthew
it must be a h Grant roll on missing
because this is the person I really feel
like I'm not watching hug Grant he's
just left he thinks he's very clever
start with Big Dave o someone else is
watching Can't par there mate move the
van don't worry friend we'll be gone in
a minute we're on news Paper Blood SP so
is John Claud vanam I'm warning you rust
does
karate he's like do
I careful boys B do
karate you know what go for you get in
the car sorry boss I'm only a blue
belt you melt I come back when I'm a
brown belt we're making a YouTube movie
hey break dancing I warning you powerful
we know all that how you tell us all
about it in the back of the
van just go in the van man they just
kidnapp him not masked up at all out
front here you're all right Big Dave
you're in safe hands now no need to
panic now in due course we're going to
press the space barar on this computer
oh
no we're going to post this
online the only thing you need to do to
stop this little creative expression
from becoming a social media sensation
lose any interest you have in the future
on Mickey pears black Mir him oh my
imagination's going into 10,000
different directions oh I would even
want to watch thatd say you
win would you want to know the truth
want to
know just his reaction that's all I need
to
[Music]
see it wouldn't have been the pig I
would have chosen is that who I think it
is yeah certainly is that'ss you're
doing I've got one more thing I need you
to do ah look I train lads to be good
lads I'm not gangster I've been forced
to do some gangster things I'm not the
gift that keeps on giv so with the
greatest respect I'll do this one last
thing for you three strikes no mail like
the genie three wishes that was a guy
Richie referenced you totally missed
yeah it's true dude freaking caller Char
H are the best parts of this movie and
he's barely in the movie he's amazing
are we ready to finalize the numbers we
already have the Situation's Chang oh
you pompous little punk I hate this guy
so much oh he's so smug you're asking
for 100 for 12 locations and a
distribution Network which was a fair
valuation at the
time H your skunk Farm was a viral
sensation on YouTube Michael yes I
follow it will take at least 3 years to
get your supply distribution and demand
back to full capacity oh my God I
calculate what was worth 400 million a
month ago must now be valued at an
anemic
130 it's not about the first Domino that
it fell it's about the last I have a
feeling we're going to get a great
monologue for Matthew mccon I'm hoping
so if you want me to help you out of
this hole you found yourself in the the
one you dug him in yeah I like your
Domino analogy the question I ask is who
tumbled the first Domo amen that's not
my concern or my business Michael at the
risk of contradicting you it is very
much your business only made one mistake
you seem to have mistaken me for some
kind of
let me introduce you to the first
Domino recognize him who is this man
what's he got to do with anything that
I'm talking about show them the picture
of them together you are in denial of so
said relationship with this Frozen China
man I don't have relationships with dead
Frozen chinen best not to be GLI at this
time in the proceedings
Matthew I'll tell you how this plays out
you will drown mic drop while you were
discussing who would take over my
business after you it you somehow
mistook so said chinan for someone else
it's nothing personal and while I am not
emotional St up there is a price
indebted to me for the blood I've gotten
on my hands restoring order to the
untidiness that you created yeah 400
minus 130 is $270 million and 670 I'm
keeping the business ooh are you are
getting in the freezer oh [__]
[__] that said I wouldn't about cuz
frostbite is very expensive on the
fingers and toes so I would type as
quickly as possible while you have the
use of them oh my God there's your
monologue as stated I am not emotional
about the money but I am emotional about
the fact that someone laid their hands
on my wife Fair Deal oh man dude that
was rough what he was about to do no
amount of money on God's green earth can
pay for that trans speci Matthew no for
that o take something from it I want to
pound a
flashh it matters not to me where on
your animate is withdrawing from
ooh but oh my God Penny short or a gram
shy another pound that freezer door does
not open am I clear good he's a master
negotiator there's your
payment come on take a
look all the files everything your
insurance policy all the photos all the
bodies all the skeletons all the filth
it's not the only one darling I'm not
among what you think in that need
you I knew you'd been following Michael
very similar our
jobs only I'm better at it than you are
God I love these gy Richie reveals got
some very important information to
impart to you Raymond when the scotch
got into your cold veins you lost the
benefit of your sharp instincts see I
kept you there cuz I needed to know
about Matthew and dry eye smart took us
a while to find your insurance
policies shoes off inside but it was
made a lot easier after I planted a
Tracker in your
shoe
ah now Fletcher what were you saying it
wasn't Lord George that was after Mickey
or drye or Matthew it was uh the guy who
they threw off the balcony some someone
related to him my guess at least 30
seconds thank you darling it's got to
keep it's got to come back right yeah
we're going to take care of this for you
Ernie's got a plan you talking about
what the Michael situation we're going
to S
it
what oh
no now you remember asland don't you no
dude you got it well this is Asen senior
Russian oligarch oh I had a feeling that
was going to come back I had to yeah
you're right and I fear that where they
failed before Raymond they're not going
to fail again again how' you know all
this because someone told them
everything they want to know about
Michael and that
someone is me
ooh so I said I'd tell him where Michael
was for a
price but that money was pending till
after know the deed was
done should have shared that information
see get my 20 Ms off Michael first after
the event get paid again double
bubble why did you just look at your
watch well it's like I say the Russians
are going to clean house and you are
part of that house Raymond they're going
to get Michael when he comes out of his
meeting oh [__] by telling you I've
saved your lives which I think in turn
saves mine doesn't it saves stuck a b
him Jesus is there a bomb in the car or
what oh
crap damn damn it and he did not like
order that hit on that kid too that was
just an accident that
sucks oh the kids said they would save
him though and they had they owe
him oh hey there you
[Music]
goas Bren
break oh they going to crash into the
car they have
to
yeah they're
Square love it love it so the todlers
spray the car with bullets killing the
Russians selling in the film I love it
he's going to get his
money he start to guy Richie so he
Airport please terminal three who's in
the
carard Charlie ham yeah yeah well well
well a man of many vacations ain't
you now I want you to play a game with
me Fletcher you like games don't you if
you wish to be the king of the jungle
it's not enough to act like a king you
must be the king there can be no doubt
because doubt Causes Chaos in one's own
demise yeah my queen told me
that
[Music]
can't no put the camera back in the
other
room
[Applause]
damn oh boy what a ride big thanks to
express vpm for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
Express exess VPN for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kdramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere
any screen protected and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com reject and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again thrilled to be partnering with
a brand I've been using for nearly two
years now and that's Harry's Razors I'm
generally more drawn to anything that
goes against the norm and Harry's does
just that in The Grooming World they saw
the high prices in the industry and
decided to blaze their own trail with
quality and affordability I keep a beer
but whenever you see these cheeks in the
neck clean and that's the work of
Harry's right there keeps my wife happy
and Harry's makes it effortless their
Precision Blades that cut smoothly with
less drag making every shave satisfying
and yes it's versatile
for other areas too you know what I mean
so as a Harry's devot I can vouch for
their value you can experience
unparalleled comfort and quality in your
grooming routine or exceptional
craftsmanship meets affordability making
a smart choice for a top- notot shave
without breaking the bank their kits and
value packs for shaving are unbeatable
but Harry's is not just about shaving
again they offer top quality
thoughtfully designed grooming products
including shampoo conditioner and
amazing body wash without the premium
price quality affordability that's a
thesis of this now these I actually
pulled right from my own bathroom I
regularly use their five blade razor
with a nice weighted handle and their
foaming shave gel man this that oh it is
a GameChanger I just like the feel of it
now I have to commit to keeping this in
my hand the whole time cuz I'm not going
to go to the bathroom in the middle of
shooting this the handles they feel perf
perfectly balanced and the razor Sleek
design is a classy addition to my
bathroom and the quality of the shave
unparalleled got to reiterate keep part
of my weekly grooming ritual cuz their
entire range of products fits seamlessly
into my routine definitely no re-shoot
here their German engineer blades are
durable and refill plans are economical
rarely use the word economical but I'm
using it now plus their commitment to
high customer satisfaction and no risk
trial makes Harry's a Nob brainer this
Gel really does feel good let me say
once more choosing Harries means quality
and affordability by grabbing your $13
trial set for just $3 at harry's.com
rejects you're not only getting a great
deal but you're also supporting this
Channel That's harry's.com rejects for
your $3 trial set stay sharp and embrace
the extraordinary with Harry's till next
time reject Nation till next time I can
understand now why we got so many
requests for that one I mean that was
old school guy Richie new school guy
Richie but there was just so many
different things but I loved all the
stylistic choices as we always get uh
the reveals that later come on uh my
favorite part of the at least per I mean
all the acting was phenomenal but I
freaking loved Colin Ferrell so much and
Hugh Grant that was just one of those
roles were like I could just close my
eyes listen to him and I would not hear
Hugh Grant in any way shape or form um
but the storyline was so interesting I
love it was very easy to follow and I
love just you know the I just thought it
was really cool um just you know trying
to the whole thing of just like the
whole King theme and all that but also
to like the whole idea of um you know uh
with I believe his name was Michael
where he wanted to buy it for a certain
price then he hired uh dryeee to drive
the price down and then you know the
whole the whole way the story was
structured with Hugh Grant and again the
reveals that later came on it just so
damn well executed and I freaking loved
it uh I got more to say but what' you
think I thought that was a brilliant
brilliant film all around um hold on one
second guys if you're listening this in
app Spotify we just watched the
gentlemen uh I just want to check out
some some things here okay so Ron tomato
is saying may not win a riter director
guy Richie many new converts for those
already attuned to the film makers Brash
wng length the gentleman Stands Tall I
don't know I feel like this is actually
a pretty solid guy Richie introduction
film yeah I think it's attainable for
anybody because the movie is very like
it it's got all the wit of the things
you kind of grew up loving with guy
Richie because there's like Studio I
mean it's mirror maximum so there's a
studio element to it because yeah like
the the films that I saw of guy Richie
you know growing up like most people uh
were you know Lock Stock and snatch and
the films that we watched are not at all
like those lately right the last few
films if if watching Sherlock Holmes
watching Aladdin and then watching uh
you know Wrath of man here and from
Uncle and while wrath man deals with
criminals it's not you know gangster
cool it's V and revenge whip snap
dialogue of of this movie I I feel like
just had such a a wonderful blend of
Personality great characters messing
with structure in the way how guy Richie
likes to mess with structure uh it keeps
your mind kind of guessing you don't
realize how invested you are in the
characters till they're on the verge of
being killed or like oh [__] I actually
like this guy I don't want them to die
you know cuz that's usually a question
that happens with me for films is like
how emotionally invested am I in the
characters a lot of times when I when I
find them in positions where they're
about to die are like oh no and then it
feels exciting when they are about to be
saved and it's it's a and like like like
guy Richie films of the before you know
a deal with criminal gangsters and and
you know criminal underworlds this is
the one that deals with a higher class
of them like a higher sophistication
Mark whereas before it's like kind of
like low-level gangsters you know and
and the Mucky grimy Parts bare knuckle
boxing and whatever you know thieves and
here because he's got like probably more
of a of a budget and the experience
you're dealing with like Aristocats and
you know you're dealing with a whole new
class of of of characters yet it still
has got whoa whoa Andrew yet it's still
got this like rounded Focus uh
throughout with um a lot of just
exciting turns and points because those
movies are I find them really fun Lock
Stock and snatch and I I think they're
like incredibly entertaining with this
one kind of gave me a
new kind of tension like those are so
stylistically cool and I love those I
really love those two films but here I I
found myself engrossed in in the
suspense a lot of the time and the tens
and then the the the the unexpected
laughs that would that would come out
via through the characters and the back
and forth uh this felt like a world like
he built a world here and I was very
surprised by uh how that world was done
because I didn't really know what we
were walking into I kind of expected to
feel a little bit more like the the guy
Richie that when he first came onto the
scene um but it's also like weirdly not
as flashy as I thought it might get and
terms of just the direction it's more
flashy in the writing you know whereas I
think with stuff like Wrath of man and
Man from Uncle that we watch it's more
flashy in the direction and I think here
like the writing actually speaks a lot
more volumes than the direction like
they're going around there's some like
cool flashy stylistic direction that are
happening throughout um but it's more um
it's more the the writing of the
characters a lot of that really uh sings
the most of me yeah no I I I agree I
love that dream very suspenseful tone
while still creating a fun environment
and uh also to uh just piggybacking off
what you said with it the direction um I
love how so many of these characters
like you know you get this calm uh
demeanor from a lot of these characters
but like in they can in a split second
can just get extremely scary on a dime
um I mean you even said too there was a
sequence where you're like we haven't
seen a Matthew MCC scene where he gets
like extremely intense and frightening
and then boom right then and there it's
like guy Richie was listening to you um
but I I I like that uh when charact
because I think that's more frightening
when characters can seem very calm all
throughout you know a film and then in
any flash or uh instance they can just
frightening come out of their shell if
you will um so I really appreciated uh
the direction from guy Richie in terms
of performances I really liked uh the
actress who played Matthew mcc's wife
like she was able to from an actress
point of view she was really able to
stand to uh you know on the same toes
with Matthew MCC and I just especially
for a very masculine movie yeah for sure
I just love the interactions between
them like they were just so opposite of
each other but they were also so perfect
for each other like the king of the
jungle and the queen I just I loved all
through interactions they were so good
yeah man yeah I think like this is a
great crime Caper with a with a with a
fascinating sort of like a bit of a
flamboyant touch I would say you know
what I mean yeah like especially like
the Hugh Grant character the the Matthew
character I thought it was excellent and
what I what I like to in terms of
casting Grant it's like I haven't seen
every call and feral role I haven't seen
every um well more so I haven't seen
every Hugh Grant role and I haven't seen
every Charlie hunm role but usually from
the roles I have seen them in especially
Hugh Grant in particular where even
watching him a Man from Uncle you're
like yeah it's like more sophisticated
Hugh Grant you know yeah yeah usually
Hugh Grant is just uh Hugh Grant to me
like I always like watching him I always
think he's a very Charming guy I think I
think he's a a star uh but he's usually
just Hugh Grant and here really stepping
out of his El he was a character like he
was a full-fledged
character and I I loved uh the way he
changed his Cadence the voice it was
very believable
sleazy um you know another cunning
character here like guy rich is great at
at at illustrating characters who are
cunning but then ju supposing it with um
a character who I feel like might have
gone to like a Vinnie Jones back in the
day uh Colin Ferell I think might have
been like a Vinnie Jones kind of
character totally that of this guy who's
like well yeah he gets he rides the line
between like you know like the world he
inhabits and the and the streets he
inhabits have gangs involved so he will
like have to once in a while participate
with the gangs but he himself is not a
gangster you know and but wanting to be
a mentor for the kids as well I I
thought was a really like that whole
introduction scene where you just think
he's going to like beat the [__] out of
these kids and then it just ends with
him saying come on the gym some like so
great and he just had like the funniest
lines and the and Charlie hunam
especially too I thought played um he
had that kind of like Elegance about him
but he's got that loyalty of like a Brad
Pit to George Clooney in the oceans
movies you know uh that kinship between
them seems like their bond extends
further past this is just some guy he
works for but the movie does doesn't you
know shine a spotlight too much on that
it's just right I think everyone's CH
like to hear that this this is getting a
series I don't know if it's just in the
world of the gentlemen if it's these
characters of the gentlemen with new
actors I don't know what they're doing
with that series but I like I said I
think here he he did build a world and
this world is one that seems like a
great one to like dabble in and it is
super super masculine film but hell yeah
man I'm here for the super mascul Kai
Richie never really makes a movie where
it's a and I'm super appreciative of the
fact like that he can subvert our
expectations so much and again it's not
subverting just to subvert but he does
it in a way that's very satisfactory and
IT services the story and the characters
and it's just so well executed when he
does it and it's to the point too when
you can rewatch these movies and go ah
okay like you can pick up on things um
and also too I got to give Matthew mccon
props that monologue at the end uh when
he was calling out Michael uh you know
like saying like hey how you you screwed
over the deal and then the froz of China
man thing and but when he said like the
whole pound of Flesh thing and then like
my wife and then he got in his face
freaking powerful acting I mean the
acting in this film was just top
freaking Notch I mean Charlie hunm scene
too with the
kids and pulled out that machine like
where where was he hiding that thing How
It Ends in that with the machine gun but
but when he's first taunting them cuz at
first I wasn't sure about the Dynamics I
in the beginning of this journey I
wasn't sure like okay am I not going to
be on the same page as everyone who's
recommended this movie because I'm not
exactly loving the way that because it
was a lot of information to kind of be
keeping up with like it's throwing you
into this world and it's turning off
into Mikey's perspective yeah and uh
it's going by pretty quick in a way
where you're like oh you got to keep up
with that guy Richie you know energy and
pace and eventually I'm not sure when it
was when it was like oh I'm really
starting to like a Groove I'm vibing
with the movie now you know cuz it is
like a dance this film and you got kind
of like as an audience ever got to you
know Dance w your way with the film as
well and and there was a I don't know
when the when the when the Pivot Point
happened for me when I really start to
like it because because in the beginning
I was a little unsure of like am I not
going to love this in the same way how I
feel like people might expect us to love
this movie it but once you attune to it
um and you and you really get a sense of
of the style yeah and the fact that it
can be yeah British banter with some fun
plot twists all the all the minations
that you love of a guy Richie experience
yet with um I think a I mean he always
has heart that's another thing too you
know like I think a lot of people often
compare a guy Richie is like oh you know
he's British Tarantino I think he's a
little bit more I don't think he's that
like I see the similarities of course
especially with this one with that has
so much cinematic references throughout
in the Cinematic uh metanis which is
something I going to say I love that so
like Tarantino especially loves to call
attention to that in a lot of his films
and I don't really associate guy I see
Guy Richie pay homage and tribute I
don't really see his characters unless
I'm just completely forgetting I don't
really hear his characters often do that
where this was so about that you know
from this unreliable narrator standpoint
of Hugh Grant talking about pitching a
film ending with pitching a film that
gets so met by the end to the point he
said mirax yeah you know uh which I
thought was really fun and cheeky and
but in a way that I think complements
the experience of this movie and and so
I I understand when people compare like
him to Tarantino but I don't feel like I
don't feel like they're they're one and
the same honestly I think they're very I
think there's so much differences
between them and especially in like the
mood and the editing style whereas this
is a little bit more of a patient
version of I would say of it's still
fast and energetic it's I don't know if
the it's a slow it's not as not as fast
as like a snatch or a Lock Stock I would
say but I wouldn't call it slow either
whatever the word is to make me sound
smart put that word there apply it here
and Tarantino is usually a lot more
deliberate regardless and and I think
guy Richie is is much more tuned to like
yeah you know writes for the edit in a
lot of ways and as usual I mean the
nonlinear storytelling just again very
meticulous and very well executed
because you can really screw that up
with bad editing and not you know
putting it in the right spot so I
thought it once again like he clearly
loves going to that technique of
nonlinear storytelling him and
Christopher Nolan clearly love that
angle and again if you're gonna do it
you got to do it right oh my God and
Henry Golding as well another guy who
play I've seen this guy in two movies we
interviewed him once for Snake Eyes oh
cool um and Snake Eyes which I know
didn't get great reviews really nice guy
we talked to him he was really funny
called John and I he said we look like J
silent B really yeah he said look like
you guys look like
especially the time when we interviewed
him we had longer hair and bigger beards
I did too and he he's like you look like
the funniest thing I got to watch that
interview uh yeah so we got to meet a
really nice guy and uh you know we saw I
he did that some Christmas movie with
Amilia Clark I forget what it was that
Christmas movie Crazy Rich Asians most
people know from that love them and the
guy wasn't even an actor he was a host
and he got crazy Rich Asians now he's
found himself in this world of acting
and I love seeing him play uh so against
type like I think he did something with
his teeth cuz I'm pretty sure the guy's
Perfect Teeth yeah and and he he
embodied like a nastiness and I loved
guy Richie you know casting actors who
kept playing against type like Matthew
mccon was the probably the only one who
did what I would expect Matthew mccon to
do he does a great job he's great in the
movie like he's very he's just
unbelievably natural at it at the same
time you're like yeah I don't know
anything about this movie yet this is
exactly what I expected from Matthew MCC
in this film uh just that suaveness that
Deon Aire quality that he brings uh yet
you know he could be like a total badass
slick monolog the way he carries that
dialogue with that southern charm uh
yeah I thought he was excellent but
everyone else the cast of characters
that were surrounded by were they all
played so much of them played against
typ just did something I hadn't really
quite seen before like Colin Ferrell has
done such a variety of roles that I
wouldn't really call it like against
type uh but hug but definitely yeah yeah
I I was very much a A Dazzle by it yeah
I was not expecting that from Hugh Grant
just cuz I'm so used to seeing certain
type of roles from him and like I said
if I closed my eyes and was listening to
that voice I would never say that's Hugh
Grant so I mean I was like you said his
character was completely fully fleshed
and I really loved him i' probably say
him and Colin Ferell were my favorite in
terms of characters in this film but all
the acting was superb in this I mean I
watching Charlie Andrew I'm paying for
two and a half hours give me like 10
more minutes of you okay all right man
all right yeah it stays in the video let
let's do
this just going to talk about the
gentleman point I'm done talk I don't
even want to talk more I'm just going to
make up [__] to talk about all right
let's do it what we got to talk about
Charlie hunam what you think oh I this
movie was making me go I would love to
see Charlie hunam and Colin
Ferrell like not just oh yeah that's a
great wish uh but but to do a movie
together or or like to Star the next guy
because even though they don't have a
lot of scenes together they had that
impact when those two were on screen yes
of this chemistry that I sort of felt
was unmatched between anybody else it's
like Charlie hunam is usually paired up
with Matthew mccon here but there was
something about the Dynamics and the
chemistry between those two characters
and the way they Rift off of each other
a lot of times in just Expressions that
they would kind of share uh to each
other that I thought M that that really
made me go wow I want to see these two
characters come back or I want to see
them staring another guy Richie film
together or starring something together
because uh their chemistry to me had so
much conveyed and communicated when they
weren't even speaking a lot of the time
yeah and they were the two that I
thought did that the strongest out of
this wonderful Ensemble of characters
yeah they only had a couple scenes
together but yeah the way they were
emoting in their face Expressions it was
just like so infectious to watch I just
yeah for sure and I love the
unexpectedness too of like the gangster
children like the kids you grow up in
the Rough Side of the these streets and
they but they kind of you grow up in
these streets you find a way a life of
crime that's kind of like the where
where you get the guiding Mentor role of
Colin frell coming in who wants to steer
kids clear from that like I said there's
it's it's grounded in a world but
there's also World building you know and
Greg they gave us one of the greatest
rap songs ever put on film yeah Oh I
thought the unexpected Ed I said that
was great because when they're all
coming in one at a time at the marijuana
Farm you you're thinking they're all
going to beat up these kids yeah yeah
with like one gu coming in after another
like all right they're about to get the
crap beaten out of them and they play
the footage and you find out never mind
that's not the case at all again that's
KY Richie's Style Just revealing
something later on love it oh no this is
a very oh I think it's a sequel show uh
cuz it's following a guy Eddie halad
inherits a large estate from his father
unaware it was from Pearson's drug
Empire huh yeah oh oh John Carlo
Esposito's in it oh as a criminal oh so
yeah it's got to be a sequel show that
makes I'm more happy about that I'd
rather watch that than a remake yeah
yeah of course and Guy Richie is
involved I would assume but even that
with like these Estates who are who who
who keep the cash flow coming in Via
this illegal weed Market uh dealing is
is a really uh compelling
again World building that that it's like
so I was going to say even if they
didn't do the sequel series I would have
been fascinated if they even if they
didn't get Matthew MCC back like you
could have casted a younger version just
showing like how he came up with the
whole IDE even though they kind of
showed that in uh just what he was
talking about with uh Michael I believe
the character's name was or Matthew it's
hard for me to wrap my head around
because Matthew is is not Matthew mccon
he's the flamboyant the guy who dicks
him over yes
correct um but I mean that would have
been interesting but again just
continuing on that that whole thing with
the Estates and all that yeah that's so
compelling and fascinating itself that I
think that warrants what they're going
to do with the series and yeah that
fascinates me enough to want to continue
on watching with that I think that's a
the smart way to go story-wise holy [__]
okay fun facts time Hugh Grant filmed
the scenes of Charlie hunam in 5 days he
had to deliver over 40 pages of dialogue
during this year Jesus 40 pages of of
dialogue five and with that tough accent
too whoa that's not easy oh they didn't
even Grant never met Matthew mccon dur
they didn't have any scen they didn't
have any scenes together Raymond's Grill
was designed by Guy Richie cool wow so
much of the are about uh Hugh Grant yeah
uh Hugh Grant wrote a cheat sheet the
night before he scheduled a shoot his
car was broken into the robber took his
script and the cheat sheet so Grant
needed to go without them damn that's
that's not tough oh guy Richie uh is
wrote the TV miniseries yeah yeah oh
sweet that's what it said was Guy Richie
working at um you called that one Richie
Brewery you called that one actually is
this and its own by director guy Richie
oh okay oh funny I just thought that was
him just putting his own I me I think
the company is him Richie yeah oh funny
there were no table readings for the
film so like guy Richie had the cast do
full rehear rehearsals with multi-angle
camera more more natural that way Richie
with then review footage of the scenes
and revise the script accordingly oh
brilliant brilliant like I said I think
it came out more natural that way I mean
I think when it comes to acting he knows
how to cast he knows how to cast he
knows how to get his I think that's why
actors you know even though some of his
films can get like mixed review like
reviews from the critics actors come
back to work with him for a reason yeah
no I have not seen again I I I didn't
really watch Aladdin I or I watched 10
minutes I didn't give it a chance but
every film I've ever watched of his act
actors wise and acting performance and
directors wise I've always thought like
I've Loved all the performances I've
watched for sure so I can see why like I
would imagine being on a guy Richie said
and working for him they love working
with him and I see that Henry kaville is
about to do another film with him yeah
it's true I think T is coming out uh guy
or it's out by the time this video drops
guy Richie has a deep interest in
fashion and was very concerned with the
Wardrobe for the film
concerned I'm concerned about the way
the Wardrobe is going down to prepare
Charlie Hunter for his role roie took
him clothing shopping to get a feel for
his character and it's funny because
part of the script is H is about uh you
know the the importance of wardrobe uh
very early on in the story many of
Michelle docker's monologues were
written or Rewritten on the day of
shooting she had mere hours to memorize
changes before Jesus I can't even
imagine how tough that was oh Kate
Beckel was originally cast of the roll
of Ros that's that's the wife right yeah
yeah I could I could totally see her I I
still think Michelle Dockery did
fantastic but I could totally see K
andell doing that role the track suits
for front of the gang were
custom man the F the attention of
fashion here very important
sting we just talked about I
accidentally mentioned sting right
before we started filming too though
never mentioned the movie fans found an
Easter revealing Fletcher first name to
be Peter at around six minutes in the
cover of the screenplay Peter Fletcher
can be seen in the bottom left corner ah
that is a funny
reference working Tils were tough guys
and
Bush no the gentleman it's more
Universal his charact rant said his
character was based on General
SAS
uh okay I've try to see there's any
quick F fact no not as fun not as fun
not F we got to watch Legend of the
sword oh King ar oh wasn't Charlie hunam
in that one yeah he plays King
Arthur and like you said actors love
coming back to work with G
Richie Gotta See Brad Pit come back to
do another film with gy Richie that I
want to say it's usually like the A-list
um you know white guys who don't come
back Matthew MCC Robert Robert Downey Jr
Brad Pit like now we're one and done
sorry buddy remember D he came back for
the sequel well I mean other than a
sequel we're one or two and done with
you after that he's like no never mind
we're too famous we got [__] to do um
but yeah man I would give this oh music
great everything great always picks out
great songs in his films I mean he can
do no wrong when it comes to the music I
can't wait to see the show I hope the
show's good if he's that directing it do
I really want to watch it though I feel
like his voice is part part of the voice
of it is his Direction yeah as long as
he's a Creator and a writer I'd be
fascinated just to take a look at it at
at minimum I wouldn't I wouldn't be
surprised if he at least did an EP I
mean they said it was eight episodes so
I wouldn't be surprised if he did an
episode I probably the pilot yeah I mean
even Tim Burton did like what four or
five episodes of Wednesday and he's
about and he's doing Beetlejuice too
right now so yeah got to imagine he did
at least one I don't know but I mean as
long as he's writing creating it I'm
going to at least have a look at it for
sure cuz I was just so fascinated by
this world it must mean it's a big film
yeah yeah I loved it uh guys what do you
think about the gentleman what would you
rate it down below is there anything in
here Andrew Before I Let You Go that you
think you did not like or could have
been improved uh hard to say right now
but overall um no it was Prett for the
most part I loved it um another great
guy Richie film uh so far I have not
seen any films of his where I did not
like I just love his stylistic choices I
love non the way he utilizes non-linear
storytelling those where he comes back
to reveal things uh subversion of
expectations uh just really solid
director I love the comparison you made
uh in our Man from Uncle video where he
obviously does not get the recognition
and I'm not saying he's as great but
he's really damn close in my mind uh to
Christopher Nolan I know take that with
what you will um but you know uh I just
really big fan of his and I'm so glad
this journey we getting to go on
watching his films he's damn good yeah
especially terms of precision and
calculation of how he how he does things
you know um yeah they make very
different films but yeah yeah of course
of course all righty guys thank you for
being here and uh we'll talk with you
all
[Music]
soon